Bonjour à tous, aujourd’hui dans ScienceClic,
que verrait-on en tombant dans un trou noir ?
Un trou noir est une régionsphérique de l'univers,
une sorte de bulle d’espace-temps,
qui possède une gravité intense.
Cettebulle attire les objets
vers soncentre, un peu comme si elle tirait le tissu de l'espace,
exactementcomme une étoile ou une planète.
Lasurface de la bulle estappelée "l'horizon" dutrou noir.
Elle divise l’univers en deuxrégions: l’extérieur, et l’intérieur.
Sous l’horizon,
le tissu de l'universest tiré tellement vite querien,
pas même la lumière, ne peut s'échapper...
On sait aujourd'hui que notre
univers contient une multitudede trous noirs.
Ils sont très lointains
et ne présentent aucundanger pour nous.
Mais par curiosité, on peut sedemander
ce que l’on verrait si l’on venaitàtomber dans l’un d’entre eux.
Répondre à cettequestion va nous permettre
de mieux comprendrecertains phénomènes
extrêmes de l’univers, et de rectifier des
idéesfausses qui circulent à ce sujet.
Au cœur de notre galaxie, la Voie Lactée,
se trouve un trou noir supermassif
qu’on appelle Sagittarius A* (A étoile)
A l’aide d’un vaisseau spatial, on s’en
approche jusqu’à une distance raisonnable,
et l’on saute dans le vide de l’espace.
Ici commence notre chute.
Elle dureraenviron 1 heure, et nous sera fatale.
Le vaisseau quant à lui reste stationné,
en orbite autour du trounoir,et nous regarde tomber.
Avant même d’entamer notre chute,
on se heurteà un problème.
Le trou noir est supermassif,
sagravité correspondà une masse
plusieursmillions de fois supérieureà celle du Soleil.
Avec une telle attraction,
il capture des étoilesetde la matière environnante,
formant un épaisdisque deplasma en orbite autour de lui.
Cedisque tourne à des vitesses
vertigineusesproches de celles de la lumière
et perd del’énergie par friction,
entraînant des turbulencesqui l'échauffent.
Il produit ainsi un intenserayonnement :
lumière, ultraviolets, rayons Xet rayons gamma,
qui nous aveugle instantanément,etrisque de nous brûler vifs.
La matière pouvantatteindre plusieurs milliardsde degrés
risqueégalement denous calciner à son contact.
Pour la suite, on va doncsupposer
qu'on s’estvêtus d’une combinaison extrêmement résistante,
qui, à ce stade, nous permet de survivre
et de filtrer les radiations nocives.
Mais malgré cette combinaison,
le disque nous paraît toujoursextrêmement brillant.
Impossiblede distinguer quoi que cesoit.
On va donc imaginer que notrecasque possède
une visière permettant de diminuer la luminosité du disque,
pour qu’on puisse observer
les détails ainsique les étoiles en arrière-plan.
Dans un premier temps,
onremarque que le disqueest bleu.
Parmi tout le spectreélectromagnétique qu’il produit,
notre visière ne laisse
passerque la lumière visible
celle que nos yeux peuvent voir.
Dans ce domaine, le disque émet davantage de
bleu, car cette couleur est plus énergétique.
C’est le même effet qui donne leur
teinte bleutée aux étoiles très chaudes.
Étrangement,
un côté du disquesemble pluslumineux que l’autre.
Pour comprendre,
la matière tourne très
rapidement autour du trou noir,
sibien que d'un côté elle se rapproche très vite,
tandis que de l’autre elle s'éloigne de nous.
D’un côté les ondes lumineusessont empilées,
on les reçoitavec plus de fréquence, tandis que de l’autre côté,
la lumière est étirée,
on la reçoit avec moins d’énergie.
C’est cequ’on appelle l’effet Doppler.
Il s’agit du même phénomène
qui se produit avec lesondes sonores
lorsqu’une voiture passe devant nous.
(bruit de voiture)
En regardant le trou noir,
on note quel’arrière du disque semble déformé,
comme s’il se repliait autour de
l'horizon, formant un anneau de lumière.
Ceci est dû à la forte gravité du trou noir,
qui dévie les rayons lumineux,
agissant comme une lentille gravitationnelle.
En regardant dans une direction,
on observedesobjets qui sont en réalité situés ailleurs.
Enfin, les étoiles en arrière-plan
nous semblenttrès légèrement bleutées.
Pour cause, on ne s'en rend pas compte,
mais le trou noir déforme letemps,
si bien que notre horloge tourne légèrement
plus lentement que celle des étoiles lointaines.
Par rapport à notre horloge, la lumière
des étoiles nous semble légèrement accélérée,
sibien qu’elle nous paraît décalée vers le bleu.
Étonnamment, pendant les10premières minutes de chute,
on a l’impression que le trounoir s’éloigne.
Pourtant, on s'en rapproche de plus en plus vite.
Mais son image semble rétrécir peu à peu.
Imaginons qu’on lance uneballeà travers une voiture.
La balle est lancée à 90°
ettraverse la voiture de part en part.
Lepassager voit la balletraverser la voiture… à 90°.
Mais maintenant,
imaginonsque la voiture sedéplace.
Cette fois, le passager la voit arriver
depuis l'avant, avec un angle plus resserré.
Parce que la voiture se déplace,
les objets qui l'atteignent lui semblent provenir
d’unedirection différente,
resserrée vers l’avant.
Dans notre cas,
à proximité du trounoir, lasituation est la même,
et les rayons lumineux jouentle même rôle que la balle.
On reçoit lalumière du disquedepuis une certaine direction,
mais parce qu'on se déplacevers le trou noir,
les rayons nous semblent arriver
depuis une direction différente,contractée vers l’avant.
C'est le phénomène d'aberration de la lumière.
Après ces 10 premières minutes,
ontombe désormais très rapidement,
à 4% de la vitesse de la lumière,
et à partir delà l’effet d’aberration n'est plus suffisant :
le trou noir commenceà grossirdans notre champ de vision.
Au fil des minutes,
on descendpeu à peuvers le trou noir.
Notre vitesse augmente,
et on reçoit la lumière devant nousavec de plus en plus d’intensité,
tandis que la lumière derrière
nous semble deplus en plus sombre.
Il s’agit à nouveau del’effet Doppler :
en tombant vers le trou noir,
on rattrape la lumière qui arrive devant nous,
alors que la lumière derrière nous
a deplus en plus de mal à nous atteindre.
Si l’on se retourne,
onremarque également quel’horloge du vaisseau derrière nous
sembletournerde plus en plus lentement.
L’effet est léger, maistout de même perceptible.
Ceci est également dû à l’effet Doppler.
Si on imagine que l’horloge
duvaisseau émet un signal chaque seconde,
les rayons mettent
de plus en plus de tempsà nous parvenir,
et on observe l’horloge tourner au ralenti.
Les minutes défilent,
et on survole peu àpeu le disque de matière.
Quand soudain,
après 57 minutes de chute,
le disque sembles’estomper.
On vient d’atteindre ladistance au delà de laquelle
la matière n’est plus capable de rester en orbite autour du trou noir.
La gravité est si intense,qu’à cette distance
le plasma se met à spiraler très rapidement vers l'horizon.
Maintenant, leschoses vonts’accélérer de plus en plus...
Seulement 2 minutes plus tard,
nous sommesdeux fois plus proches de l’horizon.
Ici, toute la lumière qui provient
de l'extérieur est destinée à tomber dans le trou noir.
C’est ce qu’on appelle lasphère de photons.
A cette distance précise,
la lumière peut même resterenorbite autour de l'astre.
A mesure que l'on s’approche del’horizon,
les passagers qui sont restés
dans le vaisseau voient notre images'estomper,
et ralentir peu à peu jusqu’à se figer sur l’horizon.
La lumière que l'on émet
a de plus en plus demal à échapper au trou noir.
Elle est reçue de plus en plus
lentement, et s’estompe peu à peu.
Levaisseau ne nous verrajamais franchir l’horizon.
Mais pour nous,
seulement 24 secondes après avoir franchi la sphère de photons,
il est temps d'atteindre l’horizondu trou noir.
A partir de là, il nous seraimpossible de revenir en arrière.
Qu’observe-t-on en franchissant l’horizon ?
De façon contre-intuitive…on n’observerien de spécial.
Il est d’ailleurs très difficile de savoir
exactement à quel momenton a franchi l’horizon.
On reçoit toujours la lumièredes étoiles qui tombe avec nous.
Onvoit encore le vaisseauqui est resté en orbite,
et dans lequel l’horloge,
même si elle sembleralentie, tourne toujours.
Et on voit encore parfaitement
notre corps, et notamment nos pieds,
car même si la lumière
est emportée vers le centre du trou noir,
par rapport à nous
elle peuttout àfait remonter, et atteindre nos yeux.
Il s’agit en réalité d’un principefondamental :
A l’échelle globale, l’espace-tempsest courbé par le trou noir,
etengendre ainsi cet horizon à l’intérieur
duquel les objets sont déconnectés de l’extérieur.
Mais àl’échelle locale,
l’espace-temps est presque plat,
et la courbure ne s’y fait pas ressentir,
si bien que tout s’y comporte normalement.
Qui plus est, contrairement à ce qu’on pourraitpenser,
l’image du trou noir, qui grossit peu à peu,
ne semblepas du tout nous englober.
Même si on est désormais dans le trou noir,
son image n’occupe que 15%de notre champ devision.
Le reste est encore rempli d’étoiles.
Il s’agit là encore du phénomèned’aberration dela lumière.
Désormais, on se déplace extrêmement vite,
si bien que la lumière qui arrivesur nos côtés,
et même dans notre dos, nous
semble provenir de l’avant.
Notre champde vision est contracté devant nous,
et élargi dans notre dos.
Notamment le vaisseau derrière nous
semble grossir, alors qu’on s’en éloigne.
On a franchi l’horizon, comme si de rienn'était.
Mais à partir de maintenant,
si l'on tente d’envoyer unsignal versl'extérieur,
il ne parviendra jamais àdestination.
Sous l’horizon tout est destinéàtomber vers le centre,
sans espoir de ressortir.
Mais même en sachant
que l'on va mourir,pour le moment tout va bien.
C’est au bout d’une trentaine de secondes,
juste avantd’atteindre le centre du trou noir,
qu’en l'intervalle d’un clignement d’œil,
on ressentune force très puissante
qui nous étire jusqu’ànous disloquer.
On parle de spaghettification.
Notre tête est plus loin du centre que nos pieds,
et la différence de gravité
est telle quetrès vite notre corps se fait déchirer.
Dans nos tous derniers instants,
on al’impression de toucher une surface plane,
qui occupe la moitié de notre champ de vision.
Comme si l'on tombait sur uneplanète complètement noire,
tandis qu'un cerclede lumière s'intensifie autour de nous.
Un dixième de seconde plus tard,
les restes de notre corps
déchiquetésatteignent le centre du trou noir.
Notre voyage s’arrête ici.
Pour le moment,
laphysiquemoderne ne sait pas décrire
ce qui se passe au plus prèsdu centre d’un trou noir.
Nosthéories actuelles décrivent des singularités,
des points où la courbure del’espace-tempsdevient infinie.
Mais les chercheurs suspectent
que ces singularités n’existent pas réellement,
et il faudrait pouvoir unifier
la gravitation avec la physique quantique,
pour espérercomprendre un jour
ces zones extrêmes de notreunivers.
Certaines hypothèses remettentmême encause le fait
que l'on puisse survivre aumomentde franchir l'horizon.
De plus, dans la réalité,
les trousnoirs peuvent posséder une rotation,
qui génère des effets étranges,
avec de multiples horizons,
etdes instabilités mathématiques
dont on ne comprend pas encore les conséquences.
Mais nos théories actuelles permettent
toutde même de se faire une bonne idée de ce que l’on verrait.
En particulier,
on peutrectifier certaines idées fausses qui sonttrès répandues.
Par exemple, le disque autour du trou
noir n’est pas orange,mais bleu.
Si certaines images le représentent orange,
c’est qu’il s’agit de fausses couleurs,
qui n’ont pour but que dereprésenter laluminosité,
mais pas la vraie couleur quel’on verrait en lumière visible.
Une autreidée qui circule
est que l’on verrait le temps s’accélérer
et l’histoire de l'universsedérouler sous nos yeux,
alors que notre champ de vision
se ferait englober peu à peu par le trounoir.
Il s’agit là encore d’une idéefausse,
qui oublie de prendre en compte
l’effetDoppler etl’aberration de la lumière.
Toutefois il reste beaucoupde mystèresà résoudre,
et il faudra attendre de perfectionnernos théories
pour savoir
ce quise passe réellement au cœur d’un vrai trou noir.